that felt like the expulsion was an
error you didn't give us an opportunity
I felt like it was retaliation
a parent breaking her silence on her
son's treatment within the Clark County
School District saying her son was
wrongly expelled thanks for joining us
here at six I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus that incident comes as
Nevada lawmakers are looking to revise
how students get disciplined in the
classroom Joshua paguero looks into
efforts to reform restorative justice in
schools he joins us live in the studio
Joshua so I want you all to take a look
at this graphic it shows when it comes
to students to spending and expelled
Hispanics and blacks make up the largest
number that's causing concern among some
groups given blacks only represent one
in 10 students and that means about a
third of them are being taken out of the
classroom
there's a problem it's late to be
addressed but it needs to be fixed
immediately
is is way overdue Tamiko Glover says her
son who attends Johnston Middle School
in North Las Vegas was unfairly expelled
it's a winter break this has happened I
can't get anywhere I'm not getting any
help my concerns are not being addressed
it's this and this no you need to do
this you need to do that and I'm like
why am I not being taken seriously as a
parent Glover ended up getting the Las
Vegas Alliance of black school Educators
involved and they sent school officials
this letter eventually Glover's son was
reinstated parents should be able to go
to a school ask for their child's
documents ask for support and get the
support that they need without having to
call outside Advocates earlier this
month lavazzi accused a white teacher at
Johnson of using an offensive racist
remark by Waters says issues like this
are why she's against reforming the
restorative justice law which was passed
to curtail the disproportionate numbers
in our state we have a high number of
students who are disciplined
disproportionately and that number of
students usually impacts black children
the Nevada Department of Education
supports revisions to the current
statute restorative justice emphasized
interventions such as writing an apology
letter rather than suspension or
expulsion as discipline nobody wants to
to suspend and expel nobody wants to see
discipline disparities occur in our
schools and we also need to make sure
that school safety for our staff and our
students is Paramount
so we went back and looked at the data
before the restorative justice law
passed in 2019 the 2017-2018 school year
41 percent of blacks were expelled while
it was 37 for Hispanics nearly identical
to this data
oh Joshua you mentioned there an
incident at one of the schools in your
story so we received a response from
that school that says in part School
administration became aware of an
incident on our campus that involved
communication that contained racial
implications School administration is
diligently investigating now as for the
restorative justice law Governor
Lombardo says he supports a change four
Republicans in the Senate have
introduced their own version of a bill
to reform that law